so I'm just trying to figure out the
time line okay so the six months ends
and then you don't go back to the why it
was like right well it wasn't like
suddenly rolling in money and getting
offers either I did end up getting at
that time a lot of interest and I was
working writing so what I actually end
up doing was I was hired to rewrite
other people's scrubs so I didn't sell
my own but a production company hired me
to do some rewrites for a couple of
lifetime movies actually yeah couple of
web 10 movies they were doing lifetime
at the time and so I did that but it
wasn't enough to completely pay the
bills and I didn't know if there was
gonna be more because every time my
project ends you don't know when the
next ones coming so so during that time
I decided I needed to maintain what I
was doing during the day I need to be
able to take these meetings with
production companies and part of working
at the Y prevented me from doing that
because of my responsibilities there so
I basically needed a job that had less
responsibilities so during that time I
worked for a temp company that that
catered to the entertainment mystery and
so I could pick which days I wanted to
work and I was also bartending at night
and so you know that was something that
wouldn't interfere yeah and then I was
wait waiting tables also so kind of
doing what a lot of people who come to
LA and do who want to be an
entertainment field do because it was
really hard to have the the job where
you could make a decent salary because
with that comes the responsibility which
precluded me obviously from being able
to go and have the time I needed to
write when I was on these projects and
eventually I could just quit those jobs
one at a time and got to the point where
I was making a living just writing wow
so that would you say it was like a few
years out or yeah I would say probably I
would say that probably was four or five
years maybe before I could get rid of
all the other jobs but during those four
or five years I was rather consistently
working now on screenplays and and
building my body of work so you could
almost sense that it's going to be
around the corner yeah just doesn't say
no when right yeah interesting how are
you dealing with being tired for
working so many jobs cuz it sound it's
exhausting just getting ready for one of
those jobs but then you still have to
keep your mind intact to do rewrites
yeah I think it's um first of all it
helps when you're your 20s I did my
parties but yeah so in your 20s I mean
you just have a lot more energy sure
okay but also you know again the writing
was what I looked forward to so I would
get up and I'd go to the job because you
have to go to the job but then I would
come home and the writing was really
something that energized me and so I
never really looked at it like I needed
to be that I was just too tired to write
I just I don't think I've ever really
felt that because for me it's the thing
that I I just want to do all the time
like I'm always so much more comfortable
with a pen in my hand and a piece of
paper and just in case I have an idea or
something so for me it never felt like
that I was just curious where did were
one of your parents super discipline did
you watch because you just have this
amazing discipline both of them were you
know my parents my dad was a very hard
worker and I think my sister and I both
got our work ethic from him he was a
door-to-door insurance salesman back
when they had those right and and he did
very well and but he was always working
and my mom was the very much pro
education she has a doctoral degree and
so I think we were just sort of this
combination of you know he never went to
college but he worked really hard and my
mom was all about you know she has
multiple degrees and so we kind of were
a mix of both of seeing both of those
people in our lives so and door to door
it sounds like you would have to be so
self
and and he very much wasn't bad he's
very self-motivated right yeah cuz I
mean that would you talk about that
first knock on that door yeah yeah it
would tell me to I mean that's
definitely not me that's not my
personality but for him you know he's
the type of person who I mean people
would say oh he could sell ice to an
Eskimo because he's just that type of
charismatic person and he loves getting
to know people and talking to them and
selling them and and he loves selling
things so that for him was a great a
great occupation
but very self-motivated because you do
have to get up every morning and you
have to decide where you're gonna go and
who you're gonna try to sell to and he
had a lot of control over that Wow
interesting
you